so you got this title yes breakout star
comes a lot of pressure because you have
to get up there give some kind of speech
yeah you got to prove why you the
breakout star of the year yeah yeah well
I haven't thought of it that way it's
it's a really cool honor and yeah I'm
excited to be here man and look at the
end of the day we're just in a banquet
hall it's the middle of the afternoon
you guys can't tell that it's 2:15 p.m.
Trevor Noah was supposed to be here
thank you yes come on the show must go
on the show must go on you know who's
gonna be here Ronnie Chef exactly and I
can't wait for his speech he's gonna
roast me you know roast me forgetting
this award that's the thing do you do
you like like giving feedback to other
communities and getting feedback from
other comedians look you you want you
you want your contemporaries to be
honest with you right yeah right yeah so
this year's been crazy for you guys so
much going on with a new daughter as
well so even find the time to fit
everything in I guess love that
beautiful photo yes their daughter
walking down this yes so how do you find
the time to do it all
I mean panic and diapers are expensive
yeah so quite explodes I know how much
they are in Canada but they're quite so
Patriot Act still going strong yes if
you find it hard to like obviously want
to push the envelope a little bit and
you've got some things you've had to
push back from sure you find that hard
to find that balance of not going too
far but still pushing the envelope yeah
I mean for me look we have an amazing
writing staff and an amazing news team
and one of the things that we've always
done is to make sure as long as we're
actually correct and were buttoned up
with our information then we're willing
to let the comedy take it as far as it
can go because I know at the end of the
day what we're saying is accurate
argumentatively
you have some advice for a Canadian girl
let me say this now she's gonna start
the show in September man yes so I need
advice for her yeah so you know what
Lily and I we've already hung out we've
talked about this before Lily just
followed my follow I told you you're
gonna do great and you're gonna be a
bust you're not going to tell us what
you told her right no actually we made a
video you know it actually comes out
coots and I line up this week okay yeah
yeah okay so the world is gonna see it
okay she got me to love and respect her
dog Scarborough which is a week both
Canada and her adorable dog or puppy and
I gave her some advice late night yes
thank you thank you
you